[Musik]
und
hallo herzlich willkommen so sally soll
heute gehts leckere zitronen pferdchen
und zwar habe ich die verkürzung auf der
livingkitchen messer in köln gemacht und
die kamen gut an dass ich gesagt habe
kommen die musik ist gleich für euch
nach wochen und waha ist es im prinzip
inspiriert von meinem eigenen backbuch
da habe ich nämlich den lämmern murray
drin also den kronen käsekuchen mit bb
haube und habe die ihf in kleiner
version mit einem leckeren mandeln
rührteig zubereitet und ich bin wirklich
super hübsch aus dem ganz schwer aber
richtig gut angeht ja die zuschauer nach
dem tag nach der wölfe gleich
geschrieben und begleiter der frau und
kind fragt und deswegen legen wir gleich
los oder gleichen zutaten für den teig
brauch ich bei 150 gramm zucker etwas
vanille extrakt eine prise 250 gramm öl
habe ich sonnenblumenöl 120 vom lehn
einen halben teelöffel backpulver nennt
viertel teelöffel natron 100 gramm
mandeln die werde ich gleich noch einmal
und etwas butter mädels und für die form
rauschen mit dem wachstum fällt zuerst
nämlich wie kommen in eine rührschüssel
wir können den teig ist entweder mit dem
handrührgerät mit natürlichen maschine
oder auch einfach mit so einem
schneebesen verrühren
denn machen zeit muss man nicht extra
schaumig rühren
der wird einfach nur ganz kurz verrührt
da habe ich jetzt noch mal ein extrakt
mit dabei den zucker und real um hier
gehe ich jetzt im prinzip auch schon das
mit rhein und ruhr das ganze was durch
damit die flüssigen zutaten nicht
unterbinden
die potentaten verrühren dann nämlich
ist nähe und die gemahlenen mandeln
damit eben hinten in meckerte werk
kleinwagen und gäbe es backpulver und
runter froh und wollte keiner von habt
könnt ihr da stattdessen backpulver
nehmen aber durch die smartphone geht
der tag noch ein bisschen besser auf und
nach vom braucht immer ein bisschen
teurer
deswegen habe ich das angebot am 11
schon kommen die trockenen zutaten mit
rein und auch schon ein bisschen mut und
je nachdem wie groß oder wie klein die
eier sind braucht jetzt etwas nervig
oder ein bisschen weniger ich habe dem
schneebesen der küchenmaschine genommen
weil sie sehr flüchtiger teig ist aber
fand ihren festen rührteig macht müsste
auf jeden fall ein flacherer oder auch
den flexi röhren in den teig fühle ich
jetzt in einen spritzbeutel ohne lokale
ihr könnt auch zum beispiel in einen
gefrierbeutel nehmen den so kammer ihn
am besten trainieren
die backform fertig jetzt mit back
display und die mache ich jetzt ohne
papierbasis förmchen weil ich sie später
noch verlieren werde und auf der messe
etabliert auf ebenen angebracht sind
deswegen setze ich viel später erst in
papierform schneide ich hier oben nur
noch eine kleine spitze ab und völlig
fernsehen jetzt etwa 34 und die machen
zeit zum vorbereiten backofen bei 190
grad ober unterhitze etwa 15 minuten
gebacken und danach komplett abkühlen
[Musik]
die machen ist ab gefühl jetzt werde ich
mich um den belag kümmern und zwar kommt
als eine debatte drauf für die bg mache
brauche zwei eine triumphale komplette
computer drucker und für die muffins
etwas lernen kann das leben kehrt habe
ich fest gemacht in meinem kühlschrank
das kann man sich super ausstreichen für
torten füllungen benutzen oder würde ich
heute für die maxime für die cupcakes
und zwar wie jetzt das budget also die
db macht wird hier über dem heißen
wasserbad erwärmt und zwar deswegen weil
ich dann nicht mehr im backofen backen
so werden eventuelle keime abgetötet und
bekommt einfach eine andere sehr stabile
konsistenz also einmal hier rein und
butter zucker und fange ich schon mal an
mit einem schneebesen oder mit einem
elektrischen schneebesen verrühren mache
ich jetzt auf niedriger stufe und kann
das wasser unten zum kochen bringen und
wird die masse von etwa sieben minuten
lang erwärmen
[Musik]
die masse gut erwärmt und jetzt mit holz
führen entweder auch mit dem
handrührgerät oder immerhin einfacher
denn befand auch ein paar minuten
ich stellte die küchenmaschine kann ich
mir glatt rühren und in der zeit von ig
markets
doch schön fett und findet in einen
spritzbeutel mit anderen stern schüler
[Musik]
und die fan für das baby auch hier gilt
extra viele packen und so sehen gleich
die bz richtig schön aus bevor ich aber
die debatte brauch kommt kommt wird
immer eine lücke von den leckeren land
gehört auf die machen frau und zwar
immer schön in die mitte
denn gleich wenn die bösen monster
draufkommen kronenbitter nach außen
gedrückt
[Musik]
beim raub spritze mitgebrachten den
spritzbeutel senkrecht zu halten und
dann wirklich in die mitte und den
kleinen super drauf zu machen
[Musik]
jetzt könnte dem anschluss noch in
papierform zu setzen und aus erwähnung
[Musik]
die taten sind fertig und duda
viele leute machen ja richtig toll
ausgemacht das ist aber natürlich auch
in großen massen förmchen machen arbeit
sind wir deswegen habe ich noch gezeigt
auf dem mist vorab gemäß verbrannt
da sieht man mal mit der tochter nicht
aufgepasst hatte doch jetzt erst mal
eingesetzt genial
sehr lecker ganz ganz ehrlich und
kraftlos dieser like sind dann hat man
die säure auf gelernt hat und dann noch
mal die triebe auf dem pc das wirklich
super lecker und falls er diese frist
nun auch nach machen wollen dann geht
auch wenn glock de
das steht noch mal die kinder nutzen
trocknen
das geht nun mal das ganze ernte rezept
und wünsche euch jetzt mal ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen und hätten zum
nächsten mal gebrannt
[Musik]